[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Florio joins us now pro football
talk live co-host and uh his mob novel
set in 1973 entitled on our way home
available uh on an ebook for $3.99 on
Amazon all proceeds go to Mike's local
animal shelter Mike great to have you
back I know you're busy certainly with
what's going on with the playoffs and
the last remaining seats for coaches
what are the odds what are the odds that
bellich Vel and Pete Carroll don't have
jobs next season well Pete Carroll
currently has gotten no sniffs anywhere
I had heard earlier in the week he was
trying to make a push behind the scenes
to get the Chargers interested too late
for that with them hiring Jim
Harbaugh it looks like both belich and
Vel are going to be shut out now I think
vel's got a chance in Seattle a chance
Dan Quinn has been the name we've been
here hearing for the past couple of
weeks that's a hard sell after giving up
48 points to the Packers in the Wild
Card round at home that's a tough sell
to the fan base to bring Dan Quinn back
now vel's a little easier to sell how
does Vel get along with John Schneider
now that John Schneider the GM is fully
in charge of everything and that is the
bigger problem I think with belich Peter
King and I talked about this today on
PFT live how do you put guard rails on
belich at this point in his life how do
you make him the head coach and say
you're just going to be the head coach
you're not going to run the show and he
says fine and then he shows up and he
starts making those faces and Grunts and
harps when the general manager says
here's who I want to draft what are you
gonna do then are you gonna give in bich
and then if you don't is he just GNA put
that guy at the bottom of the bench and
say I'm just not going to play him I
didn't want him so I don't think there's
a team that trusts the ability of belich
to work in a structure where he's not
fully in charge because he spent the
last two decades fully in charge of the
pay matriots how do you go back from
that I think that's why only one team
talk to him and no team is going to hire
him yeah but if the bottom line is
winning do you does does it matter how
you get there I mean if bellich comes in
and helps you and makes you a better
team then what would the hold up be I
agree with you you find a way to work
with a great coach the problem is you
have people who have jobs who want to
keep those jobs who don't want to be
marginalized by Bill bich working
against you I think whole Rich McKay
dynamic in Atlanta is one of the big
reasons why Arthur Blank was talked out
of Bill bich I'm told that Arthur Blank
went into the hiring process wanting
bich but bellich presumably told Arthur
Blank in their initial meeting
one-on-one now we don't know this but
this is just common sense and
circumstantial evidence I don't want
Rich McKay having anything to do with
football operations get him out of here
I don't want to deal with him I don't
want to have to answer to him I don't
want to have to talk to him I want to
run the football team you got to be
willing to let bich run the football
team otherwise there's going to be
people in the building who feel
marginalized and irrelevant and you know
just dysfunctional with belich that's
the problem anything short of saying
here's the keys drive the car wherever
you want it's going to be hard to pull
off if you were going to bet where
bellich is let's say in the next two
years I think he's going to end up in TV
this year remember how great he was on
the NFL 100 alltime team with Rich Eisen
and Chris Collinsworth I could see him
join an NFL Network working there for a
year and then see what happens in the
2025 hiring cycle now downside he's a
year older and we know that age can be a
thing in the NFL he's going to be deeper
into his 70s by next year but maybe he
needs to show and prove to people that
he's kind of humbled himself a little
bit unless somebody is willing to say
here's the keys go wherever you want to
go with the car if he has to prove that
he's humbled himself maybe will a year
from now and somebody will say let's do
it the other reality too is owners will
have a whole year to think about this
idea of pursuing belich the next cycle
instead of just having it fall out of
the sky in January they got a whole year
to think about it recap what happened
yesterday the Falcons and the
Panthers Falcons hire Raheem Morris Who
first got a head coaching job with the
Buccaneers at the age of 32 after three
years they moved on he's had experience
on both sides of the ball offensive and
Def and very highly respected was
actually the interim head coach of the
Falcons before they hired Arthur Smith
and now comes back as the head coach
that's an interesting hire 15 years
after he became a head coach how much
better suited is he to be successful
very highly respected and a lot of
people think overdue for him to get a
second chance and then in Carolina you
know a couple of weeks ago somebody I
I've known for years who's very plugged
into these things gave me a list of
vacancies and names vacancy and name and
for the Panthers it was who the f knows
and we didn't know what they were going
to do so Dave Canalis goes there from
Tampa Bay one year as offensive
coordinator with the mandate to fix
Bryce young the thing that makes that
job not attractive is you need the owner
to stay the hell out of your business
don't meddle don't tell me what to do
don't throw drinks on fans just enjoy
the fact that you've got 20 billion
please and let the football people do
the football
work yeah I was wondering about this
with belich with the Eagles he could be
waiting a year the Cowboys waiting a
year Buffalo he could be waiting a year
and then maybe swoop in to the rescue do
you see any of those scenarios if vacant
would Jerry Jones actually say to Bill
bich come on him I know when the
Patriots were going through the mental
gymnastics of what happens if we move on
from Bill bellich there was a thought in
the building that maybe Jerry Jones
would do it now and after the Cowboys
were humiliated in the Wild Card round
by the Packers there was a widespread
belief to the point where the Cowboys
felt compelled to put out a statement
that Mike McCarthy is coming back how
many times have you seen a team that has
won 12 games in a season issue a
statement three days after the playoff
exit that the head coach is coming back
you just don't say anything the head
coach is coming back so there must have
been some thought to moving on from
McCarthy now would belich and Jones
coexist there's a lot of respect there
bill bich has said plenty of great
things about Jerry Jones but does Jerry
Jones want to give up any of the
appearance that it's him who's
responsible for what happened but I
could see it a year from now the Giants
I think I'd put in play as well that's a
team that in the past he's wanted to
coach would they make a change so that
that's that's the thing having a full
year to ponder what's next is there a
team out there that is just one great
head coach away from finally getting
over the top that that that's that's his
best spot we're talking to Mike Florio
pro football talk live co-host is
precedes us on peacock with Chris Sims I
keep hearing this but there's nothing no
substance attached to it and that's Andy
Reid's
future it just and you know how this
works it's like hey you know have you
heard this or hey I heard this or and
then it starts to grow and then it's
almost to the it's a report well it's
not a report but it just feels like
something's there with Andy Reid whether
it's true or not I heard a good story a
few weeks ago that I can't share maybe
one of these days maybe if I ever do a
follow-up to Playmakers it'll be one of
the chapters but it was enough to make
me say holy crap it's on the chief's
radar that this guy could retire after
the 2023 season it doesn't mean he's
going to it doesn't mean he's thinking
about it but it's on the chief's radar
that they better have somebody ready to
go if Andy Reid walks away and the only
team in the NFL that has Patrick Mahomes
is looking for a head coach now what
happened happens when the Chiefs finish
their season who knows does he walk away
if they win a Super Bowl I don't know
maybe he's more inclined to come back
and try to be the first guy to win three
in a row I don't know and nobody seems
to know I saw a report yesterday that
one of the reasons he won't retire is
he's got two years left on his contract
well that's that's irrelevant you retire
whenever you want to retire who cares
about your contract you don't keep
working just because well I got I got
honor my contract I'd really like to
retire but boy I got honor that contract
when you're done you're done so it's one
of those there's no specific reason to
suspect it's going to happen but the
thing that I believe the Chiefs are at
least planning for it and you could say
that's obvious the guy 65 but they're at
least planning for the possibility that
whenever it's done he tells Clark hunt
the owner of the team that he's moving
on have a great weekend mike always
great to talk to you thank you bud thank
you Dan see you pal That's Mike Floria
pro football talk live co-host and
contributes to NBC football night in
America